a palavra diz pessoal daqui fala é o
rápido
aqui hoje trago-vos aqui laser contra
chocolate em
[Música]
e
eu comprei aqui este laser no eBay e eu
não sei bem a potência dele eu acho que
diz aqui tem mil MW o que a produção
miliamperes mil voos Mafra os outros
nunca
tenho medo de potência 1000 é tipo um
saco de mil grau só que é violência aqui
até dissidentes ele porque porque este é
um daqueles laser que queima tu não diz
que toca de queima isso é perigoso
pessoal não usa em casa ok isso aqui até
Vem Com uma chave aqui tipo uma chave de
proteção e o vídeo de hoje vai ser um
teste é este laser e eu vou usar com o
teste aqui o nosso chocolate ele é
daquele chocolate já tinha sobrado
daquele vídeo de faca quente eu ainda
tenho ali muito chocolate portanto eu
vou agora usar a medida que eu vou fazer
os vídeos né eu tenho aqui outros
materiais que também vou usar um balão
fósforos mais fortes só que estão postas
gigante né nem muito grande isso é que
aparece o meu causa disso é para contar
para contar por aí tenho aqui os que
seguirem exclusivos escrevem inclusive
já tive umas coisas para as faíscas
vamos lá então testar o nosso LED a pena
já tive a carregar cerca de uma hora
Como podem vir aqui eu não sei se
conseguem ver de produção e não tá e já
indica 4.2 volts O que quer dizer que já
está cheia Portanto vamos tirar a nossa
pilha e vamos colocar aqui dentro agora
vou ter que usar a chave aqui parar esse
momento em 3 2 1
vou Vejam só pessoal Este é o nosso
laser e só tu já começa a sentir um
pouco calor eu aproximar mais é que já
vai começar a queimar um pouco
acho que não queima outra que isso não
queima
e vamos queimar um chocolate os postos
eu vou então tentar primeiro queimar um
balão
um
OK eu acho que tem acesso Central já
ficou bem grande e agora eu vou agarrar
aqui o balão esta coisa que parece uma
bigorna não sei bem o que é que isto é
mas está pra gravar coisas aqui ó
[Música]
e
o que é que só reparem só que se eu
deixar aqui este talento muito aberta a
luz vai ficar muito aberta também tipo
ali fica uma bola gigante mesmo mas se
eu apertar aqui esta lente a bola já vai
ficar mais pequena O que quer dizer que
o foco já está mais concentrado né mas
reparem só
a bola tá bem mais pequena e basicamente
este laser para queimar eu tenho que
encontrar um ponto certo a relativamente
à distância do objeto em que o que é
queimar Ou seja eu tenho que estar por
uma distância certa e regulando até o
leitor queimar o objeto e é isso que eu
vou fazer aqui com o nosso balão 1
e não funciona eu tenho que achar o foco
mesmo
o [ __ ] isso é muito potente falta a
sabem segurança acima de tudo reparem só
polícia já entra no olho reflete tudo
mesmo olha essa tipo a lente eu acho que
assim vai não reprodução rir
supostamente dizem aqui que o balanço
arrebentar se tiver uma pinta preta
porque o preto vai te enxugar os raios
laser em 3 2 1
ao contrário vai 321
é só fala em sol e quando a ponta aqui
no azul a luz fica expandida e quando
vou para o preto A luz já não espante
vai lá brutal
e mesmo assim uma renda mesmo assim eu
não sei que é o foco que fala é o foco é
trocar Porque quanto mais vocês Falcão
mais conseguem e agora agora só agora
preparem-se
Paulo
telefone
Como podem ver pessoal aquilo
aliás Vamos tentar 2
ok 321
eu acho que tá mais Olha
aí o outro
E ai ai ai ai vai abrindo tarde estou a
sentir estou assim tem produção vou
sentir mais
rico em paz pessoal
toca toca lá produção pera aí
vocês já viram o leite resulta mesmo e
agora vamos tentar tem outra coisa
qualquer tipo não posso já um posto aqui
dois três Ok eu sou mais ou menos ao
mesmo nível por tantos é bem o que
queimaram o mesmo tempo Ok em 3 2 1 vai
lá olá uh
Tu viste o fundo esse filme ali
eu acho que não
acho que o resultado
tá deitava muito fumo agora
o fatos muito quase muito perto de
acender aqui o fósforo de mil grau de
quente laser milvolts
Eu acho que eu vou usar aqui um suporto
mais fixo para arranjarem aquela caixa
postal e ficou pronto são acho que aqui
vai o aditamento fundo japa muito fumo
em
toda essa caixa olha olha não não não
não não tá quase várias educaralho
acende percebi
assim tá quase
Você deu os dois logo pessoal
conseguimos acender
fósforos vamos lá tentar mais uma vez
aqui olha olha olha olha ai
mas este não é um bom inimigo para o
nosso laser super potente não ainda um
inimigo muito maior
um fósforo Mega gigante esta difícil
queimar um
tu estás a falar porque sabe que eu
assim Senhor Tá quase Tá quase Tá quase
não
conseguia fazer aqui o nosso Mega
fósforo não tem assunto Alice olha aí
vamos lá então tentar aqui o nosso
inimigo
chocolate que é preciso aqui abrir um
pouco só para aí que até tem aqui o
corte da faca Ok acho que é suficiente e
agora eu não tenho certeza se é Preciso
pintar o chocolate de preto porque eu
sai Amei castanho que sempre deve
absorver o laser Mas vamos tentar vamos
lá testar 3211
eu esqueci dos óculos meu isso dói muito
no olho a assim assim vai profissão
apontar in futsal mais apontar bem 321
vai embora e
e a queimar alguma coisa aí
e eu vou aqui pintar uma quadradinho
preto
acho que isso não pinta chocolate outra
facul
um ok já está aqui um retângulo
completamente pintado e vamos agora
visse queima já para impressão rede Ok
321 vai Olha aí meu telefone não é
a fazer efeito
acho que não né eu fui um
o Bispo vai passar chocolate
Como assim ó tu achas que se eu deixar
Tipo isso tudo escuro isso intensifica
me faz sentido achas que sim eu vou
apagar as luzes todas eu vou deixar que
o estúdio completamente no escuro e vou
deixar o laser estático contra o
chocolate tipo pra uns 10 minutos e
vamos ver o que acontece
[Música]
bom
então pessoal já não tenho aqui tudo
reparem só que já gastei o blazer aqui a
caixa Eu até tenho que fazer aqui um
buraco para conseguir encaixar a caixa
aqui aqui é só encaixar ele já começa a
queimar o chocolate porque essa é a
distância certa já portanto Já tá tudo
pronto agora é só apagar as luzes que
esperar 20 minutos e ver o que que
acontece
[Aplausos]
soma que já tá chegar bastante chocolate
mas vamos lá
321 vai Vejam Só o filme assim aí
pessoal
Olha lá até para a piscar a luz
e eu acho que se eu ficar assim vai
abrir um buraco
dá perfeitamente para vir uma hora só
que fosse muito fundo quando começa a
ter para queimar a luz acende ainda mais
pessoal sou laser abrir um buraco o
laser vai conseguir passar o chocolate
eu vou ver o mais aqui a bater na parede
e eu quero muito que isso aconteça eu
acho que tá quase parei um junto
e olha sou
eu já estou sentindo o calorzinho daqui
ela tá bem calor aqui
tá aqui ó
E aí
o
Ok vou te enviar o laser abrir um buraco
aprimorar Pera aí eu vou levar o
chocolate aqui para cima e daí pessoal
vamos ficar aqui com este vídeo Eu ainda
tenho aqui nessas coisas para queimar
portanto se quiserem ver mais vídeos com
laser comentem aí nos comentários vamos
estabelecer aqui uma meta Ok chegarmos
aos 100 mil likes Não não é 50 mil não é
60 mil não é 70 mil essa mil likes eu
vou tentar construir Ok Mega laser eu já
tive aqui uma ideia porque eu tenho aqui
uma lupa se juntaram vencer com uma lupa
Eu acho que o laser vai ficar ainda mais
potente mas eu preciso de mais leis
ainda porque eu vou tentar construir o
mega laser Se vocês deixarem 100.000
likes Neste vídeo fiquem bem e até a
próxima